we get along we live together in harmony
and peace along with our Christian
brothers we're all Americans Dearborn is
what the world would look like if people
learn how to get along
I think Islam hates us stay away from
Detroit if Donald Trump becomes
president it will be catastrophic for
the Muslim community
my parents have actually brainstormed
where we might go if Donald Trump
becomes president then I have a message
for Trudeau in Canada you're gonna get
an influx of Muslims coming your way
Donald Trump becomes president we're not
leaving the country we're staying right
here and we're gonna defeat him and not
in our own place
radical is his goal is to upset and
anger people he would do anything as a
movie star to win votes he wants to whip
up his supporters into a frenzy it is
hurting
not just the Muslim community but any
minority dollars from shredders only
puts Muslims lives around this country I
at risk
you